anybody and welcome to awesome comics
your one-stop shop for everything comic
book entertainment I'm your host Walter
Bernays yak and our regular panel for
today will go with to my left mr. Brian
Porter how's it going how you doing you
have miss Heather Roose hey and we have
an away okay all right guys last week we
talked about that resubmit we're gonna
move on from DC to marvel today and
we're gonna talk about my pal daredevil
here
season two of daredevil I hit Netflix a
couple weeks ago I think we've all had a
chance to digest it by now what did you
guys think we're gonna go first
no spoilers and I'll give you guys a
warning for spoilers if you haven't seen
yet so no spoilers
Ayana I loved it I liked it better than
season one I know some people will
disagree with me but I loved season two
it hit the ground running
I was excited from episode one to just
finish the rest of it I loved it I loved
it
okay Porter I thought was fantastic like
it was it was everything that the first
season was and it just completely
expanded on that it was perfect it was
amazing just everything about it was so
good and they just built on an already
amazing first season second season was
fantastic and I liked it better I mean I
enjoyed it I thought it was really good
but I thought first season was better I
enjoyed first season more I did really
like with the season that they built a
lot of the secondary characters up more
really enjoyed that yeah I agree with
you I mean I think Punisher I think
universally is it pretty much everyone's
favorite part of this this season in
terms of my thoughts on it I loved it
alright it's still probably the best
superhero show ever edging out to flash
mean just by a little bit but yeah in
just these 13 episodes incredible stuff
I think season 1 was still a little bit
stronger I think we had with Wilson Fisk
in there as the main villain and the
growth of Matt and and foggy and Karen
and everyone was a little bit done and
handle a little bit better in season 1
season 2 still great I love it I mean
this is like this is still next-level
stuff right here but I just think season
1 was just a little bit better it didn't
drop off much
and I'm still excited to see what they
do more if they're gonna go into
defenders after this or whatever the
heck's going on with season 3 I'm not
sure they've really made that
announcement yet but so overall we
really really liked it all right
absolutely
we can't really say much just about
spoiling it so we're gonna have to go
into spoilers if you haven't seen it
what are you doing with your life if you
haven't seen it I think anything that's
superhero related right now I think you
should be watching this do you guys
agree oh absolutely
right movies included I think you should
watch this above anything else that's
out there right now we're gonna go into
spoiler talk now okay so I want to talk
about punisher Jon Bernthal is freaking
amazing and I loved and I loved him I
loved him what did you guys think of Jon
Bernthal as The Punisher he's got some
really great friend Castle monologues
too he's got some really they really
played it to you all of his strengths in
general action wise monologue Wow
just in general really really spot-on
casting oh yeah I mean I agree with
everything it was his character was I
think the most compelling of anyone else
this season I always wanted more of him
I wanted to see where his story was
going what his motivation was he just
was a really well-built character all
around and the acting was fantastic I
thought he was fantastic too and the
thing was I wasn't like going in I
wasn't really a fan of the casting
because you know I knew him as Shane on
Walking Dead I never thought he was that
strong of an actor character in the show
and I just was like man a friend of mine
my friend DJ was saying that it that was
his fan cast like he he wanted him to be
it when he found out it was like oh my
god amazing I was like okay we'll see
how he does he comes out and he just
freakin nails
he was he blew me away with his acting
abilities like that monologue scene in
the cemetery
absolutely yeah oh my god that was
brutal yes and he just delivered it so
well and it was it was perfect and every
other scene that he had the diner scene
with Karen it was like episode 11 that
wasn't his best monologues when he's
just when he gets a little room to
breathe and just deliver something
top-notch
my favorite parts of this show is like
these little character moments and
there's nobody who does it better this
season than Jon Bernthal is a Punisher
like oh my god
the okay I know we're a little bit
divided on this rooftop scene from
episode three but that's where three
daredevil is chained up to the Punishers
basically hold them captive kind of and
they're arguing about their ideologies
and stuff Punisher is arguing that it's
totally justified for him to kill these
murderers and rapists and stuff and
Daredevils on the side were like no
everybody has good in them like if you
kill them there's no chance for them to
be redeemed what do you guys think of
that scene between Matt and Frank okay
well I think I'm the dissenting voice
here that's why I won because I've been
saying one of my least favorite things
about daredevil season two was daredevil
man Murdock right
because he was just constantly in
everyone's face about you can't kill
anyone you can't kill anyone like I'm
it's this holier-than-thou almost
pompous thing and that was the moment
when I started being like oh you gotta
tone it down you know I'm I understand
that he fights for his ideal and he
wants this ideal that no one kills and
everyone has this good in them but it
just came across to me as kind of
pompous it was all self-serving like oh
I don't do this I am better than you
because I don't do this okay wouldn't
even see the Punishers point of view
that's just my opinion I think but as
the series they're the season went on I
thought he kind of he kind of conceded
to punisher that maybe yes especially
when he's like a zygote you know well
maybe and then he crosses himself or
even says yeah and it's like for someone
to be so religious to the fact that they
cross themselves for even consenting to
a hypothetical situation that might not
come to pass that he's gonna kill
someone that totally shows the depth of
his character the depth of his faith and
like how deeply seated he wanted to
remain good and never never crossed that
line how he just like I might do it just
for the sake of this one man right and
maybe in doing so I can save this one
man man's soul right and like I thought
it was a fantastic like character
development format as far as just
battling against everybody else was like
yeah
go kill a bunch of people like I don't
care and he's just no like it's really
good right I mean his morals kind of get
tested to a really good point in this
season so but that's my I love about my
Murdoch in this and Charlie Cox is
portrayal of him is that he's just so
he's so inherently good but he has a
dark side to him that you know that
comes out when he's beating the living
crap out of his dark side came through
really well in Episode three right there
well yeah there's okay so in episode
three there's a big stairwell scene
that's quiet kind of reminiscent of
season one big hallway scene that was
all one shot they kind of tried to up
the ante with that in this and he's
going down the stairwell and beating the
crap out of everybody if you see it you
know what I'm talking about you have a
gun taped to is amazing that you can use
a gun or so many things eventually I
love the king when he's walking through
he just screams and he hits the chain in
the lights and they explode see how
pissed he was fantastic episode three
was yeah was I texted both of you guys I
was just like okay episode three
probably one of these single greatest
episodes in television history I've ever
seen in my entire life I thought it was
perfect like I was saying sweets you
actually liked it hits the ground
running like it does it starts right in
it goes right in she went right away and
you're like yeah first four episodes I
think are really good like little mini
series for the Punisher like you know
what it starts off reintroduces
daredevil all the characters that we
know from the first season and
introduces Punisher as sort of the main
antagonist sort of but you can tell he's
an antihero you know it more you see him
and he's more stuff he's the most
sympathetic character on the show I
think the stuff with the lecture let's
talk about that so after the fourth
episode we go into Electra's storyline
and I thought that was pretty weak I
mean was it wasn't terrible by any means
I mean it's still good I mean just for
this show the quality level that I'm
used to it didn't quite meet that and it
was kind of murky motivations and
everything
it was all kind of explained at the end
but but at the end you have daredevil
like professing his love for a lecture
I'm like I'm only alive with you like I
thought that was way over the top and
and it didn't really fit with what came
before that what did you guys think of
the Elektra stuff I liked her being the
there was like the dual worlds of going
with Karen who like brings out the good
in him or going on Elektra who brings
out the bad in him which I thought she
was awesome I was a fan of a language I
had to look up the actress I was like
who is this she's like French Cambodian
black belt cheese yes that's awesome
yeah like she I like her a lot I think
she's a great looking electron I like
her costume she gets a suit up at the
end you like her better than Jennifer
Garner what's wrong with you let's start
off with the fact that that first scene
together made way more sense than the
last time we'll get you honey would you
think of a like Turner storyline I
enjoyed elements of it so I kind of
liked that she had that chemistry with
Matt because I was not a fan of Matt and
Karen for the most part I liked her I
thought she was a good character she the
actress was definitely great I think she
was pretty well written although there
was one line after she slices the throat
of the kid and she's got blood all over
her knees and Matt's like oh my god what
did she yes she's holding she's like do
you still want me just like a little
weird little force kind of like super
psyched psycho like misery tight yeah
but other than that I thought she was a
pretty strong character her story arc
was a little drawn out a little like
confusing at times but for the most part
I thought it was pretty strong not
nearly strong as the Punisher and yeah
like that but I liked it I thought it
was good okay I wasn't bored right sure
the hand in this season is a big part
that comes in later that ties into the
Elektra storyline and that's you know
like I like the fights and everything
you're fantastic like it all was great
climax at the end of the season
everything I just think it's just
because it's not as compelling as the
punisher stuff to me it was hard to reel
get into all that stuff like like you
know going after a lecture and stick
coming back I was in this one stick came
back but when they found out a lecture
was like the main you know their God or
whatever black storm the black sky yeah
yeah it kind of was like uh can we just
see more punisher stuff because we kind
of get a matte like not being able to
like hear and he has like this smashing
the glass thing like that whole thing
was cool and then we add the hand in and
he can't hear them and then there's the
bit when he sticks like just they have
to exhale at some point I love that yeah
I don't know like Matt gets to just kick
butt and get fat and kickback and
kickback but then when there's something
when he he can't even see your sense
then right there just adds like another
element of danger for him as daredevil
looks like oh he there's actually like
something at stake here he may not be
able to get out of this I love that oh
yeah I love that scene - it was really
good and you know they have to breathe
some time I thought it was really
awesome the hand I thought was utilized
pretty well I love Nobu coming back cuz
I thought he was a badass from the first
season and like I thought it was cool by
the hand I don't know yeah I mean they
had the Punisher story built up so well
that it just didn't do much for me
and I kind of felt like it still wasn't
very well built at the end all we know
is that a lecture as the black sky at
the Ultimate Warrior well she's the
Ultimate Warrior then why was Nobu so
kind of easily able to beat her you know
like I just feel like they spent the
whole season being like black sky good
let's go in a little bit about Karen so
the sigh I mean she has a really big arc
this season
I mean besides just the the stuff going
on with Matt she takes over for Ben
Urich so she had a lot to do this season
girl can I catch a break though
but what do you think of Karen's art
this this season outside of the Punisher
I thought hers was the most captivating
for me at least because she did have so
much to do she was always out doing
something and I think part of my
annoyance with Matt does come from the
fact of how like almost cold he was to
her during this time like you said she
couldn't catch a break
and you could tell she wanted to talk to
somebody about it and she wanted to tell
him but figured that oh well he's got so
many other things to do and whatever but
I kind of felt like she only liked Matt
because he saved her and she had that
good memory with him and that's kind of
the basis of everything where I felt
like she had better actual chemistry and
banter going on with fog so when that
happened I was like no I don't want this
so it's kind of glad to see him
distracted and be like good it was yeah
episode four or five is that's right
when I loved that scene - I thought it
was great and the chemistry between
Karen and Matt is perfect it's like how
do you have that much chemistry on
screen and not have something off of
screen I actually looked it up to see if
they were together because they had such
good chemistry like the way he was I'm
gonna you're Karen right now the way
that he was like she was like caressing
her her thank you he's caressing her arm
and she was like visibly shaken you
could see the goosebumps or whatever
like that was perfect yeah it was
perfect did you feel it arm touching
great any time she was on screen with
castle The Punisher
like in the diner scene oh yeah yeah I
thought the diner scene like everything
every time we talked to her especially
like how he he apologized to or like you
know you were fine you weren't in any
danger in the hospital like I you know
do you know what a scout army scout
sniper is like it were the best like I
wasn't gonna get you you know I only
want to talk to her like I loved their
scenes together great chemistry in a non
romantic way that it's just they worked
so well together on screen she really
brought out a lot in him yeah she
brought forth his emotion so through her
castle was made a better character and
that's what you want for your characters
and I thought she was a shining example
of like a secondary character but really
really stepping it up and I thought she
was used perfectly right and I'd loved I
loved her she was great we have kingpin
back know he showed up it was great yeah
it was great stuff the Punisher was very
good the one scene with him and Matt
when he's basically threatening him and
foggy just just slamming him down yeah
great work lover when max Matt throws
that punch
oh yes the son of the boxers really good
I loved it I loved his scene with the
Punisher when he throws him after he
gets the hole trapped with all the other
prisoners like as soon as that happened
I was like also like worse like
regulated cellblock ever because
literally every single one of them had a
show yeah right I was like okay like one
or two but literally every single one
had a different threw that stinky beer
got all Buffy with it yeah nice yeah I
thought it was great the the brutality
of the Punisher he cut that dudes throat
at the end of that fight and like all
there's blood just spilled on his face
and he's just a monster like the makeup
department for keeping his bruises and
stuff consistent I noticed that and I'm
like that was me that was great because
like you know every time you see him
some bruises heal
some that he gets yeah he's never liked
except for like the first episode that
he was in he never had a clear face
about the entire rest of the season he
messed up yeah even his hands they had a
bunch of yeah you want to talk a little
bit about the costumes yeah I loved the
costumes like I said before the I hated
that freaking headpiece in season one
well for someone who needs all the
senses and needs to be able to move and
understand like the helmet could have
shifted like this showing half his faith
and he would have never known I did not
like season one no no this one was cool
and the first one I liked okay and then
they upgraded it again I was like oh
it's even better I loved it I absolutely
loved it it's not like that super bright
red they still kept it like really dark
so they did the same thing with the
lecture though they didn't put her in
her full red I was a little bothered by
Electra's last costume though still
leaving this board and then that's the
first place she gets she got of course
well good it was realistic exactly she
would get you're gonna cover I was
breathing excited right at you when they
finally got out like this I was like oh
she's just gonna like just be kicking
but fine and then he pulls him out and I
was like punisher flashlight and mouth
just spray-painting there that that's
look good with the lines on it people
being able to just get magical powers
for sewing in their costumes that always
happens I don't understand that I don't
like it but the whole like pulling it
together out of just like found stuff or
going to a tailor giving it time I love
that I did like the the nods to Jessica
Jones Trinity pour gas they're talking
about like you know Jessica Jones and
then
Dawson's character and you know I get
this one guy but like I loved all the
little little Easter eggs and little
shoutouts to the other parts like really
bringing it together
yeah okay final thoughts on daredevil
season 2 great fantastic very strong
amazing TV show yeah definitely one of
the best TV shows ever seen in my entire
life I can't wait for more it's just
perfect right for me daredevil remains
my favorite superhero TV show just
barely edging out the flash
I love the flesh but daredevil it just
it's too deep it's too good so I'm
season 2 not quite as strong as season 1
but ice to you to me but I see less ok
so right now we're gonna get a little
couple of thoughts from a friend of ours
maybe maybe you've heard of him his name
is angry Joe so we're gonna cut to an
interview with him right now
hey you folks I got a special guest for
you it's angry Joe we're gonna talk a
little bit more about season 2 a
daredevil like we're on the set a man
so season 2 a daredevil yeah a lot of
people are saying that this is as good
if not better than season one I like
season one a little bit better what are
your thoughts what your thoughts on this
before freaking crazy man are you
serious
can I cuss Dickey's okay those people
are fucking crazy the first season of
daredevil way better than season two I
think season two season two was awesome
don't get me wrong I enjoyed every
minute of it
but I felt like the the the boss fight
was a little weak at the end I felt like
it it sort of took its time and then
sort of rushed there abruptly at the end
and what it was doing with the Punisher
and then electro was interesting but it
was you know a split focus yeah and it
a little hard I wanted to see more
Punisher to be honey you okay
everybody's in time I mean I think
Elektra is freaking awesome and they did
her justice probably better than you
know pretty good but you know I I think
that it it felt a little scatterbrained
you know for for building up in the
previous season one they talked about
the hand and they talked about this
coming war yeah and we got to see it in
season two that was a lame war man that
is the fucking lame wasn't too much no I
did like them fighting ninjas but I
wanted more right yeah well it seems
like they're gonna do something else I
mean with the end you know we have
Elektra you know being in that vat of
blood or whatever the heck that tomb
thing was yeah but that was the war that
was the competition the first time they
fought against that I know in didn't it
it should have been a little bit better
you know I felt like the fight with Nobu
what was it yeah there's a Nobu as it
was better in the first one and and so
you you have to top the previous one but
yes I don't know um I'm excited for
season 3 though they do season 3 well
sure I'm sure they well I'm not sure if
they're going to you know they were
really you know confused on whether they
were gonna do a season 2 for a while
well I think as they wanted to come out
with everyone's first season first like
Jessica Jones and Luke Cage crazy
greater Marvel knows how to do their
shit I mean they're doing what they did
they're taking their success with the
movies and they're doing the same thing
on television it yeah it's great um you
know a lot of people are talking about
Jon Bernthal as the Punisher as Frank
Castle I think the first four episodes
were so strong because they were all
just about his initial coming into New
York and everything and sort of it it
sort of ends his arc or part of his arc
there and then you know it goes on
further when he's in jail and stuff but
those first four episodes are so I know
it's like they shut the door on him and
he's got a fight like 50 it was
basically the daredevil hallways yes for
Punisher exactly Punisher gets his own
hallway scene it's perfect cuz it's in
jail and he shame
yeah exactly and he's I just think he's
so interesting I mean like all the even
the besides the big fights and stuff the
conversation she has with Karen the
conversations he has with daredevil on
the rooftop in season three I really
know his his tortured car anything it's
not this hokey you know sort of
sometimes the comic book Punisher gets a
little crazy and a little too light and
happy and kind of weird things this one
was you can tell that there is a reason
why this guy has lost his oh yeah and
his killing Pete right I mean such a
strong character in this season and they
never had to flash back to his kids gone
you know they never did and to
accomplish this amount of gravitas
without having to do that yeah pretty
cool I think the the big dolly shot they
have when they showing for the first
time at the carousel it's like that's
all you need you just see his face and
like everything has just told you know
through his emotions on his face and
everything I was not sold on in my first
really really was I thought it was a
terrible choice was it just the casting
you yeah the cast because I wanted you
know our traditional flower I wanted a
Thomas Jane Jane oh that would have been
cool yeah but after I saw his
performance I was like okay he nodded he
really didn't he was great he had a lot
of really great quiet scenes I'm a lot
of great like we're talking about the
hallway scene you know that also
involved kingpins come back what did you
think of kingpin come down that was good
stuff yeah that's exactly what kingpin
would do and I'm happy I didn't expect
to see him and I saw and so that was
really cool and and Punisher knows that
he's being manipulated right right but
he knows he's gonna get something out of
it what he wants get the hell out of
jail and go and do what I want to do
yeah so I thought it was is it necessary
Alliance for the time Punisher he's not
he's not daredevil no doesn't give a
shit you know so I really liked his
appearance and it's setting up that he's
had all this time to think about his
previous battle in daredevil exactly
when this guy comes back oh yes yeah
it's gonna be great you know in
comparison to Punisher let's talk a
little bit more about a lecture because
us on the set we're a little bit split
about whether that was that strong or
not I thought it was just kind of okay
me a lecturer self great and everything
just like I think that it's just it sort
of pales in comparison to the punisher
stuff you know like it whenever the
electra stuff is being pushed forward I
was just like where's my shoe though
like I see where's Punisher right now
yeah I liked it I like I did like it I
would err on the side of liking it
because she was you know the scenes
where she's trying to pull the darkness
out of Devlin and and sort of manipulate
him to cross the line and she surprises
him with you know the guy that was
responsible oh yeah and yeah flashback
scene was great yeah so I'd liked I
liked that she was like the dark side
and you you were thinking yourself maybe
could their double go go bad right
but yeah so I liked Elektra I thought
she was cool I gotcha
um the stuff with Karen and man I
thought was really strong at first I
mean their chemistry is like
off-the-charts long rape the scene in
the rain that my time yet the for a
movie scene I don't feel like I was like
that might be the best like rain kiss I
was in and that's maybe why people a
little mad at electric cuz you got that
started huh and then electric came in
and don't fuck it up exactly what I mean
and so I was a little pissed off at
Elektra you know and that's probably
what people are still mad at her and
they don't give a full credit but I like
the Elektra stuff but yeah so I guess
they teased us a little bit with little
bits right we have to wait till season 3
right there are sons of bitches better
make season good you know I think they
will I mean it's so popular like it
might might be a while because we got
the Luke Cage preview at the end of this
they're gonna be doing the defenders at
some point we're gonna get iron fist so
I'm not sure if it's gonna you think all
of those before I don't that was the
original plan but I don't know what it
is now come on they might come out with
that Punisher series now that's been the
rumor so they gonna do well I guess if
all these other ones are making good
money and then Jessica Jones surprised
yeah so you're right you're right it
probably yeah full-on Punisher and armor
with the symbol
you can see the van but overall I still
think like still you know one of the
best interpretations of a comic book
character I've ever seen yeah yeah if
daredevil was a 10
like I or a 9 or 10 I have to think
about 9 or 10 but yeah there does 9 or
10 I think daredevil season 2 overall
for me would probably be a 7 ok you know
overall what they were doing is an 8 but
they really disappointed me with the
resolution and the final fight and the
Han material Punisher awesome electrum
an awesome Han material lackluster so-so
maybe a little bit of a sophomore slump
just because the first season was so
cool always great and I think that it's
gonna go back up here for season 3 I
eventually do it angry angry Joe folks
thank you so much for joining us we're
gonna find you uh angry Joe show calm or
my youtube channel at youtube.com slash
angry Joe show
okay well back to us on the set this has
been angry Joe Walter days yeah thank
you guys that's bullshit Frank that's
bullshit
oh hey so what we're gonna do now is do
the Pick of the Week Ayanna as god this
week and take it away my biggest week is
a guardian devil daredevil it's written
by Kevin Smith some of you may be
familiar with them it's really really
good there's some great artwork in here
there's some Karen here should go
through a lot again of course there's a
really good set we get a little bit of
Doctor Strange in there so if you're
looking forward to that whole franchise
read this check it out
I also love the little a little forward
in here it's been out like wow this is
how many like five years this is before
yeah before your daredevil but he has
this little forward in here and it's
really sweet it's really nice it's good
stuff there's a little bit of a theme
with a baby in here you get some black
widow baby doctor strange there's some
good stuff in here check out entry it's
worth it great okay well that was a lot
of fun you can join us next week
four awesome comics right here I'm
Heather Ruth here Brian Porter there
Ayana weight everywhere I'm Walter burn
a dziak and until next time we'll see
you on the next page
you